حكايتها ليست من وحي الخيال
انها واقعنا
النوم
بعد التحميله في عام 2018 دخل قانون
مناهضه العنف ضد النساء حيز التنفيذي في
المغرب
ويهدفوا الى توفير الحمايه القانونيه
للنساء ضحايا العنف من خلال اربعه ابعاد
تهدف الى ضمان الوقايه والحمايه وعدم
الافلاط من العقاب والتكافل الجيد للضحك
كثيره
هل يتم تطبيق هذا القانون على ارض الواقع
بالفعل وهل يحمي النساء المغربيات من
العنف على الشرطه الشرطه
الا انا رحت عندهم الصبح
ما عندي حدا يعني في كل مره ترفع دعوى
الطلاق يعنفها اكثر ويجبرها على التنازل
عنها والبقاء معه في حياه لا تقدم لها
الكثير من الخيارات
فاما ان تنفصل عنه رغم كل تهديداته لها
بالقتل ودون وجود ماوى لها ولاولادها واما
ان تبقى في هذا العذاب بشكل يومي وفي ظل
رفض اهلها لتلاقها لعدم قدرتهم على
اعادتها وفي غياب تطبيق حقيقيا وفعال
للقانون من يحميها
بدنا يوصل العالم
يعني
مثل النساء
[موسيقى]
حكايتنا كلنا لنرويها ونسمعها لعلنا ننهي
العنف ضدها في يوم قريب